all right so this video is all about
what it's like to be a step dad
[Music]
what's up guys today we're going to be
talking about something i think a lot of
you guys
have been dying to know for new
newcomers
um and my isaac's biological dad no i'm
not i am the stepdad
i get a lot of comments and dms asking
what it's like to be a stepdad and some
of you guys have even reached out to me
asking me for advice on how to be a
stepdad because a lot of you guys out
there
are also in the same situation as i am
as for advice i'm not too sure if i can
give any solid piece of
information just because i've always
approached building family as a
trial and error kind of situation so i
can only speak on my own experiences
and what it's been like for me to be a
step dad to isaac i met him when he was
four years old and now he's 12
he's a pre-teen he's even started
shaving so it's been mind-boggling to
share that experience with him
but speaking of shaving before we get to
the stepdad stories this video is
brought to you by
harry's it is a men's personal care
brand
reinventing the way you shave
[Music]
this is tight everything you need for a
smooth shave
all in one bundle so at harry's they
believe every man deserves
quality craftsmanship simple design
modern convenience and a great
shave and this is their starter set
which includes
got a razor some shaving gel with aloe
that's awesome
oh this does have a nice feel i like
this got a nice weight to it nice rubber
grip comes with the
travel cover and check it these are
harry's newest and sharpest blades ever
they just came out with these i'm gonna
give them a try right now
i don't have much to shave today
wow hey not man so harry's guarantees a
close and comfortable shave and they
conducted a study where they had guys
shaving four times a week and even by
the eighth shape the guys were saying
it's as sharp as they were when they
were first used
you can get harry's new blades and the
starter set for just three dollars all
you need to do is go to www.harrys.com
tiffanycase to get the discount check
out the link in the description below
and give harry's a try i'm gonna have to
cop another set for isaac for sure
i'm raising a man he's growing up he's
shaving now it's wild so i met isaac
when he was four years old this is one
thing i've i've thought about
for a long time in terms of my pains uh
in terms of transitioning into being a
father figure mind you i was 24
and having lived the bachelor of life
for quite some time and just a very
careless and carefree
kind of lifestyle in la and and kind of
getting into the entertainment industry
having a family while getting into the
entertainment industry
isn't exactly gonna be the smoothest
uh combination of things i would say not
that it's
you know impossible but having a family
does make it hard
so when i signed up to be a step dad or
at least a father figure at that time
i didn't realize how hard the transition
was gonna be for me and even while i was
going through it i don't think i
realized how much
stress it created for myself and only
looking in hindsight now
do i realize how hard it was and how how
much
tiff was helping me through it so first
off i think i was a pretty selfish
person
uh when i first met tiff and met isaac
and i guess you know rightfully so when
you're in your early 20s
you're just a variation of being a
teenager entering the workforce
for the first time and you know really
trying to figure out what i want to do
and how to get there as well in terms of
a career so
when i got into a relationship with tiff
signing up to be
a father figure was kind of like it kind
of veered away from
the path that i had been focusing on
since you know college
so for a good i would say four years i
was
i had this one path this one direction
and then i fell in love with tiff and
the thing that tiff did to help me ease
into uh being this father figure was
that she
shielded isaac away from me for a good
six months when we met like i didn't
meet isaac
you know me and tiff will go out on
dates uh whenever
you know to get a babysitter situation
set up but yeah so tiffany's really
mindful and and very respectful in terms
of
the expectations are um in our
unification i guess
and i really really appreciate that
because i think you know had i
just jumped right in i don't think i
would have lasted very long so tiff
slowly rolled out the responsibilities
for me so in the beginning when i
finally met
isaac more or less i was just a playmate
you know i didn't have any
responsibilities with isaac you know i
would come over
hang out with tiff and hang out with
isaac and i was you know
kind of like a friend tiff would be the
one to put him to sleep
tiff would be the one to really feed him
and
and to really engage with them in terms
of you know the survival
of isaac you know in terms of fun with
isaac i was the guy to do that and it
wasn't until maybe a year
into our relationship did i really start
to
gain a little bit of responsibilities
with isaac and by this one year mark we
had to start moving fast just because of
some unforeseen circumstances tiff uh
needed to move out of her place
and at that time i had just moved into a
new apartment and i could definitely
have used the
help with rent and whatnot so tiff moved
in with me and so
having tiff move in i've automatically
made isaac
a roommate of mine as well being a
roommate quickly became being a father
figure and i started getting some
responsibilities
tiff really baby stepped and made sure
that i was ready to take on the
responsibilities before
um really dumping it onto me and i
really appreciate that but some of the
stupid stuff that i
you know had to deal with with myself
was like oh man i can't watch red
r movies in front of this kid anymore or
i can't listen to rap music no more or
you know like there's a lot of stuff
that
my stupid brain at the time just didn't
register as like
no duh and you know what's really
strange too in terms of how i felt at
that time was it felt almost impossible
to see myself as a father
figure for me growing up my own father
he was pretty successful by the time
he had me and so for me i'm i am like
wired to think to be a father you have
to be financially stable
you have to be you know like you have to
have made a certain couple steps in your
career
before having kids but by jumping into
this relationship with isaac
i veered away from that and i had a bit
of a hard time rewiring myself and
accepting the fact that hey you can be
younger and be a dad
and hey you know you may not be as
financially stable as your own father
was
but hey you can still make it work oh
another thing is my parents i actually
when i got into a relationship with tiff
i was kind of shy i was a little shy
to share that information with my
parents just because i thought that they
would
reject tiff they would reject the fact
that she had
a child already and boy
was i wrong they didn't even hesitate to
welcome tiff into their family
and to welcome isaac into the family i
think something that really helped my
parents
accept tiff and isaac into the into
their lives
was the fact that tiff did a fantastic
job with isaac and how well tiff has
managed to raise him
as a single mother uh was a testament to
tiff
and i think my parents saw a lot of
value and a lot
and gave tiff a lot of respect for that
so to my surprise
they welcomed them with open arms and
we've
traveled all over the world ever since
and we've had a lot of good times
together
and i love seeing my parents embrace
isaac as
as their own grandson and we just made
it work i think
for our family it's you know a big part
of it is just acceptance
you know i think for whatever
differences we have
different backgrounds different cultures
at the end of the day
love is gonna prevail love is gonna
transcend all
and love is really all we really need
love and acceptance
and i i love my family for that i love
tiff and isaac for that and i love my
parents for that
so it's been eight years of knowing
isaac and
um it's been fun it's been the greatest
adventure
and there's something about being a
father that i think is
the silver lining for all the challenges
and all the
the hiccups and all the bumps along the
way the silver lining is really
as you become a father figure to someone
and this goes for being a biological
father as well when you become a father
you end up growing up yourself if you're
not a parent there's a there's just a
portion of you that is
you're allowed to be a child you know
like there's just there's this
x factor uh up until you know you have a
kid and you realize your
your protective genes your whatever it
is starts to kick
in and your instincts go i need to
raise this being and i need to raise
this person to be a man
one day if it wasn't for isaac in my
life i would definitely be a lot more
childish
but isaac's taught me a lot about
responsibility
and and just maturing and growing up and
managing my own
uh emotions and so isaac if you ever
watch this video i thank you
for helping me grow up as well
i'm helping you grow up you help me grow
up another interesting
factor in our relationship is that um
isaac's dad is in the picture so it's
not like i am the step dad that takes
full ownership of that title of being
the father i actually share that with
his dad and i know a lot of you are
curious like do i do i get along with
this dad
and yes we all get along and i think
that's the best part about this
unification this family dynamic isaac
literally has three parents
and the fact that his dad comes over and
we hang out sometimes
and um and we get to kind of just group
up and team up
and talk about how to handle certain
things certain things about isaac i
would say we make a pretty good team
and we've definitely figured out what it
means to be
a parent in our specific dynamic and
ultimately we know what's the most
important thing here
it's to serve isaac's childhood it's to
serve him growing up
and making sure that he's gonna you know
grow up in a into a good
decent person like any parent would we
got three players on team instead of two
players so i
i feel like we actually have it easy
being parents
if there was one piece of advice it's
understand
what you're signing up for when you
become someone's father figure
because that that is a commitment for
life because the worst thing to do is to
be
completely attached to this child and
then to just bounce one day
for me and tiff it's kind of like we
pretty much got married the day we
decided to make it
official you know a real relationship
and
and the day she invited isaac into my
life
that was the day we got married that's
how i like to see it
we just make it work i love it i love my
family if any of you guys that are you
know becoming step dads or our step dad
shout out to you guys shout outs to all
the step dads out in the world
feel free to leave a comment let me know
if you have any advice for me
i'd love to hear it and uh until next
time peace
[Music]
[Music]
you